there's wyatt he's the most beautiful
baby ever
wyatt's bright eyes and big smile
lit up the screen as a seven month old
joined his dad anderson cooper
and his co-host kelly ripa on cnn heroes
over the weekend he is gorgeous and
perfect
and i love watching you become a dad
yeah it's been my favorite thing this
year and amazing
so cute wyatt wasn't just there to bring
a smile to our
faces no this virtual visit
was for business the baby boy made a
special cameo
to help honor the young wonders on cnn
heroes
he wants to come and play i know it's
very sweet
i'm gonna go get him okay no
it's been such a sweet year watching
anderson step into the role
of fatherhood the journalist welcomed
wyatt
via surrogate back in april in addition
to
his heart warming social media post he's
also been bonding
over the experience with his close
friend
andy cohen where's ben
where's daddy yes
andy welcomed his one-year-old son ben
last year
and from the looks of it it seems as if
ben and wyatt
are on their way to being besties just
like
their dads in november anderson called
into siriusxm's andy cohen live
and the two opened up about a
breakthrough moment
that happened between their sons during
one of their weekly
play dates i feel like for the first few
times
ben didn't really you know want anything
to do with wyatt or to even acknowledge
him but
i feel like last night we was kind of a
milestone don't you
yeah it was sweet because i was playing
uh with them both and
uh and yeah and then just wired on on
the cheek
and hugged him and it was so cute and he
did that a couple of times
yeah so it was my heart kind of melted
me too it was we had a we had a
breakthrough yesterday with those two
e.t spoke to andy back in may when wyatt
was
nearly a month old so watch what happens
live host
dished on how he and anderson are
tackling fatherhood
together i get a new picture every day
and he's so cute and he's wearing all of
ben's hand-me-downs and
he's got a great wardrobe ready for him
and it's so funny because
i just sent anderson a picture of ben in
his pajamas this morning i go do you
like these he goes i love them i can't
wait
so i said okay they're you know when ben
outgrows them they're heading to you so
we have a little uh funnel of clothes
from my house to his i love that and and
is it true that you
gave anderson your nanny i did my nanny
now works for anderson
oh that's nice so that's working out
well for everybody what has surprised
you most about
anderson as a father or or has anything
even surprised you about um
nothing surprised me yet because i it's
just i just
expected i just expected
this is what i expected i expected him
to
uh to to love it
and be tickled and be sweet and be
cooing and
uh so it's exactly what i thought would
happen
you